und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend europa war schon ein bisschen
stolz auf sich innerhalb von stunden
hatten sich 27 staaten geeinigt sich die
luft piraterie des machthabers von minsk
nicht gefallen zu lassen
der ja einen flug aus einem eu-land ins
andere hatte abfangen lassen um einen
oppositionellen blogger hinter gitter zu
bringen
da gab es sanktionen sofort gestern
heute muss europa sich schon fragen
lassen was das wirklich bringt so das
offizielle ziel der eu nun den jungen
roman prothese beach und seine russische
gefährtin freizubekommen
das muss man schon ganz nüchtern fragen
thomas reichert bericht selten waren sie
sich in diesem saal so schnell so einig
kein langes abwägen kein stundenlanges
verhandeln
sogar um ganz viktor orban macht diesmal
mit es soll neue sanktionen geben gegen
belarus der reaktion auf die festnahme
auf das was merkel ein beispielloses
vorgehen der belarussischen behörden
nennt sie ist da wir sind der meinung
dass es sich um den bruch von
internationalen abkommen handelt und
wenn die völkergemeinschaft
zusammenarbeiten will dann ist das nicht
akzeptabel schon seit dem letzten jahr
gelten eu-sanktionen gegen 88 belarussen
darunter auch lukaschenko und sieben
organisationen für sie gelten
einreiseverbote ihr vermögen wurde
eingefroren die neuen sanktionen sollen
weitere bälle russische offizielle
treffen 1 3 milliarden euro
investitionsprojekt der eu wird
ausgesetzt und der europäische luftraum
wird für belarus gesperrt erreicht hast
oder müsste die eu mehr tun
im fall der velaro sanktionen haben eben
die eu staaten relativ wenig zu
verlieren bei sanktionen gegen russland
beispielsweise ich das schon ganz anders
aus da geht es um andere summen
deshalb ist da auch immer der widerstand
deutlich größer als jetzt im fall von
min
ob lukaschenko aber wegen der neuen
sanktionen einlenkt ist mehr als
fraglich
er hat die opposition brutal
niedergeschlagen das angebliche
geständnis des journalisten roman botta
service sei erzwungen worden sagte sein
vater der befürchtet sein sohn soll in
der haft misshandelt worden
das sind nicht seine worte und das ist
nicht seine art zu reden es ist klar
dass er den text abliest
er wird dazu gezwungen wo man kann auch
gar nicht gestehen was ihm vorgeworfen
wird weil er keine massenunruhen
organisiert hat in moskau aber bejubeln
putin treue lukaschenko ein abgeordneter
der kremlpartei einiges russland
schreibt zweifellos hat der kgb von
belarus seine aus operativer sicht
glänzende spezialoperation durchgeführt
und die chefin des staatlichen
russischen auslandssenders rt meint ich
hätte nie gedacht dass sich belarus in
irgendeiner weise beneiden würde aber
jetzt bin ich es irgendwie väterchen
gemeintes lukaschenko hat seine rolle
gut gespielt wir wissen dass die
sicherheitsorgane von belarus und
russland eng zusammenarbeiten dass die
kooperation zwischen beiden seit der
niederschlagung der demonstrationen im
august letzten jahres noch einmal
deutlich verstärkt worden ist so dass
eine solche operation nicht ohne
politische rückendeckung aus moskau
denkbar ist
schmid fordert deshalb nun auch gezielte
sanktionen gegen russische offizielle
die linke im bundestag fordert
stattdessen etwas ganz anderes müssen
deeskalierend der westen wie der osten
dazu müssen wir unsere politik ändern
und ausland muss seine politik ändern
das wird aber nicht geschehen wenn wir
gegenseitig die sanktion erhöht
besänftigen oder dagegen halten das ist
der konflikt eine gemeinsame position zu
lukaschenko zu finden mag schnell gehen
eine zu putin aber seinem schutzherren
das ist die eigentliche herausforderung
für europa er glaubte irgendjemand in
brüssel dass die gestern verhängten
sanktionen reichen um roman protosevich
freizubekommen
nein die eu staats und regierungschefs
wissen schon genau dass sie mit ihren
sanktionen
dem lukas schinko regime das ja
maßgeblich von russland gestützt wird
nur einige nadelstiche versetzen können
und mehr nicht
es ging bei dieser reaktion der eu auch
maßgeblich um die europäische
selbstachtung die es nicht zulässt dass
eine solche dreiste aktion von
lukaschenko die ja immerhin ein
europäisch registriertes flugzeug und
europäische fluggäste betraf dass diese
aktion ohne antwort geblieben ist nun
ist aber die offizielle forderung in der
luft die beiden müssen sofort freikommen
wie kommt die europäische union von der
palme wieder runter ohne dass die beiden
freikommen die europäische union kann ja
die jetzt verhängten sanktionen und
flugverbote eine weile aushalten
sie hat sie ist mit ihrer ersten
strategie nämlich einer gewissen
gutmütigen einem gewissen gutmütigen
vorschlag des dialogs bei lukaschenko
gescheitert und versucht es jetzt mit
etwas mehr härte
dahinter aber steht natürlich die frage
ob die 27 eu staats und regierungschefs
und chefin
denn nicht doch auch eine genauso einige
position zu einer russland strategie
finden könnten und versuchen könnten mit
putin in irgendeiner weise wieder einen
zugang zu finden um dort die freilassung
von potosí fisch zu erreichen
danach sieht es im moment leider noch
gar nicht aus es gibt keine einigkeit in
der eu bezüglich russland und es gibt
auch noch keine russland strategie aber
die frage wie man mit diesem autoritär
werden denn russland was auch seine
nachbarländer ausstrahlt wie man mit dem
in zukunft umgehen will
die wird bleiben und sie wird immer
drängender dankeschön für die
einschätzung die deutsche afd hat heute
ihre spitzenkandidaten für die
bundestagswahl bestimmt geführt in einer
mitgliederbefragung basisdemokratisch
also daran gemessen nicht so super
erfolgreich 48 prozent der etwa 30.000
parteimitglieder haben abgestimmt
nur 48 prozent dabei war klar dass es
nicht nur um eine personalie geht
sondern um die marschrichtung der partei
71 prozent der afg mitglieder stimmten
also gegen einen kurs der mitte und für
einen kurs der die vorstellungen
offiziell aufgelösten rechtsaußen
flügels mit einbezieht dafür stehen
nämlich die sieger das spitzenkandidaten
die uhr aus tino kubala aus der
erfolgreichen sächsischen afd
und alles weil der zuletzt eher erfolgs
armen chefin der afg baden württemberg
die beiden haben ein recht unbekannt
geblieben dass du der gemäßigten
geschlagen und den noch parteichef jörg
leuten gleich mit berichtet david gefahr
dass der tag der entscheidung nicht der
tag der einheit ist zeigt sich an den
teilnehmern der afd pressekonferenz das
siegerduo weidl kubala ist da nicht aber
parteichef wollten
wichtige termine in brüssel das zeigt
sich aber auch an der einfachen frage ob
der wenigstens persönlich gratuliert
habe ich bin noch gar nicht dazu
gekommen an wirklich alle nachrichten zu
lesen
vielleicht ist da ja auch eine nachricht
von jungen leuten und mit dem ich jetzt
bisher direkt ansprechen konnte ich weiß
nicht wo du auch die offizielle
beglückwünschen reicht mir ein großer
sieg 71 prozent wollten weidl und gruppe
eine niederlage für den abwesenden
parteichef neu dessen favoriten joana
und joachim wundrak kommen auf nur 27
prozent bei mitglieder votum der
generalleutnant im ruhestand
politik-neuling wollte der partei mit
seiner vita ein seriöseres image
verleihen
die digital politikerin das neue
freundlichere gesicht werden
doch die mehrheit folgte diesem aufruf
nicht statt dessen klang die fdp
aufstellungsversammlung zum bundestag
zuletzt eher so
sitzen ihr da oben wir zeigen gestalten
von der bezahlung in folge zu schrott da
wird gerechtigkeit weil dann richtet
dass leute sagen gerade euch läuft mit
group allah und weil hat das wunsch du
das offiziell aufgelösten rechtsextremen
flügels gewonnen der wie mehrere auf die
ost verbände vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird
wir wurden ja mit 71 prozent gewählt und
das ist ein eindeutiges mitglieder votum
und dieses votum ist lager und strömungs
übergreifend ansonsten hätte man das gar
nicht erreichen können
doch in der afg verschiebt sich was das
neue lager dünnt aus schrittweise er
noch bürgerliche partei mitglieder und
mandatsträger gehen wie zuletzt ein
europaabgeordneter und enger weggefährte
morgens in ein parlament ist keine
kirmes oder krawall bude und es ist
legitim wenn man sich für das gegenteil
entscheiden mag nur das ist kein weg den
ich persönlich und manche andere vor mir
eben mitgehen wollte oder möchte der
eine partei erntete zuletzt bei einem
landesparteitag buhrufe aus dem
sogenannten gemäßigten der andere
parteichef leuten wird heute aus dem
radikalen flügel zum rücktritt
aufgefordert die afg hat nun
spitzenkandidaten frieden hat sie nicht
guten abend herr kubala genannter kleber
sie haben klar gewonnen ihre mitbewerber
haben klar verloren ging es da nur um
personen oder wurde da auch eine
richtung gewählt und eine andere
richtung eben nicht gewählt ja ich denke
in erster linie ging es natürlich auch
um personen in dessen freue ich mich
dass mit einer promovierte volkswirtin
und einem handwerksmeister dass ich ja
auch selten dass zwei politiker in einer
abgeschlossenen berufsausbildung haben
wir hier klar geworden haben und
deswegen denke ich ist das entscheidend
gewesen
nun sähen viele schon auch eine
richtungsentscheidung überhaupt in ihre
beiden mitbewerber haben offensiv
wahlkampf gemacht mit einem wahlkampf um
die mitte
sie haben extreme forderungen vermieden
nationalistische töne vermieden
haben die an die mitte der gesellschaft
deutlich appelliert und jetzt sieht
jeder dass man in der afg damit keinen
blumentopf gewinnen kann
ja herr kleber da muss ich sie
enttäuschen also das haben wir genauso
mit frau weiter getan genauso ich wie
sie wissen bin ich im landkreis görlitz
direkt gewählt und verfolge dort genau
den gleichen kurs natürlich gibt es bei
uns unterschiedliche strömungen ich
denke die als parteivorsitzender ab
integrativ genauso wie auch frau weiter
als fraktionsvorsitzende und denke das
hat den ausschlag gegeben haben sowohl
die mitglieder im blockiert nun werden
sie auch unterstützt von mitgliedern des
extremen flügels und böcke oder von
herrn kalbitz in brandenburg dieses
privileg hatten die beiden anderen nicht
das sagt doch noch eine menge aus über
die richtung in die sie gehen wollen ja
wie gesagt er habe verschiedene
strömungen dieser partei das heißt nicht
dass ich in diese richtung gehe
diese verstromung diese strömung gehören
zu einer pluralistischen partei zu einer
volkspartei ganz normale zu es gibt in
jeder partei strömung in unserer und das
kann wie können wir vereinen das ist
wichtig und der erfolg raten den neuen
bundesländern gibt uns auch in diesen
bereichen recht wir müssen jetzt nach
kroner sehen oder bzw
noch ist ja corinna nicht beendet mit
den wirtschaftlichen folgen umzugehen
dort antworten geben im sozialen bereich
aber auch im wirtschaftlichen bereich
das wird hauptaufgabe auch im wahlkampf
werden das wollen wir gemeinschaftlich
tun und das werden wir auch mit prokura
und hamburg machen die in sich übrigens
sehr fair in diesen innerparteilichen
wahlkampf verhalten haben und jetzt
freue ich mich auf diesen
gemeinschaftlichen wahlkampf sie zeigen
keinerlei zurückhaltung wenn es darum
geht auch in dem extremen lager wo zum
beispiel auch der verfassungsschutz
verfassungsfeindliche bestrebungen ortet
um verständnis um unterstützung zu
werben indem sie die positionen dieser
seite wieder geben auch in ihren
erklärung ihr wissen sagt kleber sie
benutzen ja dieses wort extrem auch sehr
gerne und das natürlich das training der
öffentlich-rechtlichen die uns natürlich
immer in diese ecke schicken wollen und
dass der verfassungsschutz politisch
motiviert ist das sehen wir in vielen
verfahren die werke sehen schauen wir
uns auch mal die vergangenheit des
verfassungsschutzes an zum beispiel das
celler loch wo der verfassungsschutz
aktiv mitgewirkt hat
aber natürlich auch die ganzen
geschehnisse um den breitscheidplatz der
verfassungsschutz er sich wirklich um
den politischen extremismus kümmern und
der snf die nicht zu finden dann schauen
wir doch mal in ihr programm sie fordern
den austritt aus der europäischen union
jedenfalls so wie sie heute ist sie
fordern 0 familiennachzug für
flüchtlinge damit schrecken sie
konservative unionswähler ab die sich
auf christliche werte berufen und dann
haben sie platz in ihrem programm für
forderungen wie die bundeswehr müsse
mehr chorgeist mehr deutschen geist und
mehr deutsches militärisches liedgut
pflegen
an wen wenden sich solche forderungen
fangen wir doch mal mit dem wechsel an
den sie erwähnt haben wenn man die eu
auf einen nenner bringen will das kann
man doch ganz plastisch darstellen
sie stecken mir auf der linken seite 30
euro in die tasche und nehme 100 euro
auf der rechten seite hinaus das ist
aktuell die eu wir sind ein geberland
geworden oder eine transferunion und das
muss in dieser form beendet wäre so
haben sie weiter zu haben so auch nicht
überragend wenn es auch anderswo
geholfen werden soll ja geholfen ist ja
das eine aber wir müssen uns auch mal
gedanken machen warum ist dann zum
beispiel großbritannien aus dieser eu
ausgetreten
vor allem wer übernimmt jetzt die doch
exorbitanten hohen zahlungen bezahlen 13
milliarden zusätzlich pro jahr weil
großbritannien ausgestiegen ist weiter
in die eu
wir sehen also überhaupt kein
reformwille in der dieser eu und das
kritisieren wir zurecht also ich denke
deswegen habe ich das heute auch schon
so erwähnt ein totes pferd kann man
nicht ewig reiht man sollte irgendwann
auch absteigen und sich überlegen wie es
mit diesem europa weitergehen soll wir
stehen für ein europa der nationalen
staaten das wollen wir bringen wir
wollen diesen zentralismus aus brüssel
zurück wieder in die nationalen
parlamente bringen dass dort auch das
volk mit entscheiden kann was die
entscheidung angeht noch mal zum großen
bild ihr wahlziel ist jetzt
offensichtlich die spd zu überholen das
ist ja möglicherweise ein relativ
bescheidenes wahlziel machtoptionen
haben sie ja nicht oder übersehen wird
aber im bund nun wenn wir die spd
sollten überholen dann hat mir wirklich
sehr wohl machtoption wir werden als
starke opposition wieder in den
bundestag einziehen wir brauchen wir
sehen dass wir ein
starke opposition in diesem bundestag
brauchen wir sind meiner meinung nach
einzig wahrnehmbare opposition derzeit
die grünen agieren weiß gott nicht mehr
als opposition im deutschen bundestag
wir sehen auch die kriegstreiberischen
wirkung der grünen die aktuell
demokratie ne konflikt deutlich geworden
ist wo wir und wo ich auch ganz klar
sage wer die grünen auch wert weltkrieg
und deswegen wollen wir hier auch ein
gemeinsames europa mit russland zb
zusammen das gehört für uns zum
wertekanon in dieser in diesem europa
dazu wenn sie das sagen mit der bitte
grünen die die den krieg promoten was
sie tatsächlich fordern ist das oder
sich nicht entgegenstellen wollen wenn
verteidigungswaffen klare
verteidigungswaffen an die ukraine
geliefert werden könnten
das als eine kriegs position zu
bezeichnen ist glaube ich ein ein
einzelpunkt der afd
aber das brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr
zu ende zu diskutieren
der wahlkampf beginnt wir haben ihre
ausgangsposition gehört wurden abend
herr pofalla guten ab und wir haben
dieses gespräch genauso um 21 uhr
geführt gestern abend waren die spitzen
der eu abgelenkt heute kam ihr gipfel
zur eigentlichen tages da ging es um die
umsetzung der verschärften klimaziele
der eu über die kontrovers diskutiert
wurde
osteuropäische länder wie bulgarien und
tschechien halten die geplante
schadstoffreduzierung um 55 prozent für
nicht machbar
bis mitte juli plant die eu kommission
konkrete gesetzesvorschläge um die bis
2050 angekündigte klimaneutralität der
eu zu erreichen
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
will an unterschiedlichen vorgaben für
die einzelnen mitgliedsstaaten je nach
wirtschaftskraft festhalten
die ständige impfkommission hat noch
nicht entschieden ob sie eine generelle
corona impfung von kindern empfehlen
wird erst müsse geklärt werden wie
dringend kinder die impfung zu ihrem
eigenen gesundheitsschutz bräuchten
sagte stiko vorsitzender mertens
präsenzunterricht oder urlaub mit den
eltern
seien keine ausreichenden gründe für
eine impfung zuletzt hatte
gesundheitsminister sparen kindern ab
zwölf jahren ein impfangebot bis ende
august in aussicht gestellt das erste
gipfeltreffen von us-präsident beiden
mit dem russischen staatschef putin soll
am 16 juni in genf stattfinden
es gehe darum die berechenbarkeit und
stabilität der beziehungen
wiederherzustellen so das weiße haus
die us-regierung wirft moskau hacker
angriffe vor auch auf die letzte
präsidentschaftswahl belastet sind die
beziehungen zu dem durch die
inhaftierung des russischen
oppositionellen navalny nach der
waffenruhe im nahen osten bemüht sich us
aussenminister blinken um die
verbesserung der beziehungen auch zu den
palästinensern und kündigte finanzhilfen
für den wiederaufbau des gazastreifens
an
israels ministerpräsident netanjahu
sagte er zu es werde sichergestellt dass
die terror organisation hamas nicht von
den hilfen profitieren
blinken sagte palästinenser und israelis
verdienten gleichermaßen sicherheit
freiheit und würde
nach gesprächen mit
palästinenserpräsident abbas kündigte er
die wiedereröffnung des us konsulats in
ost jerusalem an
als der konflikt im heiligen land wieder
aufbrach als die militant islamistische
hamas tausende raketen auf israelische
städte schoss und israel mit luftwaffe
und artillerie alles aufbot um im dicht
besiedelten gazastreifen punktuell zu
vernichten was die hamas dort an
infrastruktur hat da schlugen
querschläger des hasses auch in
deutschland ein tief verwurzelter
antisemitismus verband sich mit neu
importierte und da halten über deutsche
plätze hasserfüllte parolen in deutsch
und in vielen sparen
das war nicht nur hässlich es ist auch
eine echte gefahr dass es so nicht sein
muss und gewiss nicht typisch ist hat
peter kunst beobachtet wo zuwanderer
zusammenkommen die ein neues leben
aufbauen wollen und nicht alten hass
wer nach deutschland kommt bringt sein
weltbild mit seine verletzungen
auch in hannover trugen palästinenser in
diesen tagen ihren zorn auf israel auf
die straße viele verstehen nicht warum
hierzulande so klar flagge für israel
gezeigt wird warum bei aller freiheit
der politischen meinung
judenfeindlichkeit nicht hinnehmbar ist
mahmut khalifa demonstriert nicht er
studiert in hannover
journalismus derzeit digital 2015 kam er
nach deutschland geflüchtet aus syrien
wohin seine palästinensische familie vor
zwei generationen vertrieben worden war
antisemitismus verurteilt er israel aber
ebenso frei ist ein besatz von gemacht
ich weiß nicht die palästinenser auch
haben das recht ein land zu haben
ich bin alles palästinenser hier in
deutschland bin ich da hin los und
geklärt wenn ich in einem behörde bin
und spreche mit der mitarbeiter
normalerweise ist fragt mich woher
kommst du ich sage aber ich komme aus
palästina schreibt er auf den rechner
und sieht das land palästina nicht
mahmut zu hause ist jetzt hier und er
belegt neben dem studium einen
gemeinnützigen dolmetscher kurs für die
teilnehmer war deutschland die
verheißung von sicherheit freiheit
toleranz als sie herkamen
sie sollen künftig für migranten in
ihrer muttersprache übersetzen werden
damit zur brücke zwischen kulturen
wir haben redefreiheit und wir erleben
dass wir das aber in verschiedenen
situationen ja anders interpretiert wird
neuer job wird künftig sein dass wir
quasi dolmetscht und das werte neutral
macht das der mensch der mensch ist und
dass jeder für sich seinen eigenen wert
hat toleranz einüben sich öffnen für das
leben der anderen eine herausforderung
auch in der kurs pause
meine mutter ist eine russin und vater
waren sehr gut dass wir in der modernen
welt bei dir frei kommunizieren
trotz unsere würzen großes problem ist
also was die israelische regierung dort
macht sonst wir haben gar nichts gegen
juden und wie gesagt wir können immer
zusammen leben und das haben wir schon
das habe ich mir schon lange zeit und
hunderte alles schon gemacht
zusammenleben barrierefrei und
deutschland als neutraler boden auf dem
das möglich wird
das hat auch estland und deshalb werden
sie am ende dieses kurses anderen
migranten über die hürden deutscher
sprache und bürokratie helfen und im
besten fall auch über die hürde vieler
mit ein reisender vorurteile
gerade erst hat die bundesregierung
beschlossen die einsätze der bundeswehr
im westafrikanischen mali zu verlängern
und aufzustocken
gefährliches terrain auch wenn
kampfhandlungen nicht der auftrag der
bundeswehr sind die sahelzone ist
drehscheibe für terrorismus organisierte
kriminalität und menschenhandel
die sicherheitslage in mali wird immer
schlechter dschihadistische gruppen
genießen in weiten teilen des landes
bewegungsfreiheit und dann putschte im
august letzten jahres auch noch das
militär versprach wahlen die jetzt
täglich unwahrscheinlicher werden und
die militärs setzten sich fest
da stellt sich doch immer mehr die frage
was die bundeswehr dort noch zu suchen
und zu riskieren hat unser afrika
korrespondent berichtet noch bevor der
protest beginnt werden die demonstranten
von einem polizeiaufgebot gestoppt
das aber ändert nichts an der wut der
aktivisten an dem die co
die ereignisse der vergangenen nacht als
das malische militär einmal mehr
politisch eingriff und dem präsidenten
und dem premierminister festsetzt das
ist eine demütigung für die menschen in
mali ein rückschlag für die demokratie
und den demokratischen übergangsprozess
erst im vergangenen jahr hatte das
militär in mali geputscht eine
übergangsregierung sollte den weg zu
demokratischen wahlen im kommenden jahr
bei einer regierungsumbildung aber
fühlte sich das militär um den starken
mann und vize-präsidentin oberstes ziel
gold offenbar nicht genug eingebunden
und angemessen vertreten und riss die
macht an sich die internationale
staatengemeinschaft reagiert empört auf
das vorgehen des militärs tätig und was
operierenden militärs erneut gemacht
haben ist ein inakzeptabler
staatsstreich innerhalb eines
staatsstreichs das fordert eine
umgehende verurteilung und wir sind
bereit in den nächsten stunden gezielte
sanktionen gegen die akteure zu
verhängen wenn sich die situation nicht
klärt sie belegt wie protagonist wie
frankreich ist auch deutschland derzeit
mit rund 1000 soldatinnen und soldaten
in zwei missionen in mali militärisch
vertreten
denn terrorgruppen halten das land seit
dem touareg und islamisten aufstand 2012
in atem
ab juni soll das deutsche kontingent der
europäischen ausbildungsmission tm sogar
deutlich erhöht werden der erneut der
staatsstreich der malische armee aber
werfe fragen auf sagen experten ist es
ganz offensichtlich dass die bemühungen
den sicherheitscheck so zu reformieren
dass cairns viele dieser mission bisher
nicht wirklich erfolgreich gewesen sind
und letztes jahr hat die eu nach dem
kurs letztes jahr entschieden die
ausbildungsbemühungen zu pausieren
dieses schild kritisiert wieder garten
mali kommt nicht zur ruhe die neue
politische unsicherheit könnte die
ohnehin instabile lage im land noch
weiter verschärfen
das wirtschafts thema war heute die
geplante mega fusion auf dem
wohnungsmarkt der immobilienkonzern wo
nokia will die deutsche wohnen
übernehmen für 18 milliarden euro ist in
stünde
europas grösster immobilienkonzern frank
bethmann und das mit dem versprechen
dass die mieten nur begrenzt steigen wie
realistisch ist das ja das muss sich
noch zeigen fakt ist dass es die mieter
künftig mit einem neuen vermieter
giganten zu tun hätten und dass die
ankündigung dieses zusammenschlusses
mitten in die debatte um bezahlbares
wohnen fällt erst am wochenende proteste
gegen steigende mieten in berlin gerade
hier ist die not groß aktivisten fordern
sogar die enteignung der beiden
immobilienkonzerne die es zusammen auf
über 550.000 mietwohnungen bringen und
jährlich mit einnahmen von über drei
milliarden euro erzielen würden
andererseits trotz dieser größe am
gesamtmarkt vermieteter wohnungen in
deutschland hätten die beiden dax
konzerne auch künftig nur einen anteil
von 2,4 prozent die aktien beider
konzerne reagieren unterschiedlich für
die deutsche wohnen geht es heute über
16 prozent nach oben
wo novia dagegen mit einem minus von
sechs prozent größter verlierer im dax
vor allem weil der zusammenschluss teuer
wird um den deal zu stemmen will wo
novia neue aktien im wert von acht
milliarden euro ausgeben
eine kapital verbesserung die bereits
heute kräftig auf den kurs drückte
vielen dank nach frankfurt jetzt ging es
überraschend schnell mit der
unterschrift sagte selbst hansi flick
der nun definitiv nach der fußball-em im
juli bundestrainer wird der dsb k einzig
dieses aktuelle foto heraus peter arnold
über hansi flick den nachfolger seines
früheren chefs joachim löw hansi flick
also soll für frischen wind sorgen
personell und sportlich erkennt der dfb
bestens bis zum wm-titelgewinn 2014 war
der 56-jährige acht jahre lang schon
einmal als co-trainer von löw bei der
nationalmannschaft tätig
meine vorfreude ist riesig denn ich sehe
die klasse der spieler gerade auch der
jungen spieler in deutschland so haben
wir allen grund die kommenden turniere
zum beispiel die heim-em 2024 mit
optimismus anzugehen
sieben titel mit dem fc bayern in den
vergangenen eineinhalb jahren
hansi flick versteht es größten erfolg
mit großer empathie zu verbinden
ja es ist sehr gute entscheidungen für
den dfb nicht nur weil er den verband
kennt sondern weil er jetzt bei bayern
münchen auch eine beratende arbeit
gemacht hat die erste aufgabe für den
angehenden teamchef die qualifikation
für die wm 2022 in katar die kommende em
kann hansi flick dagegen noch ganz
entspannt aus seinem urlaub verfolgen
bei uns ist gleich hannes jaenicke im
einsatz für den wolf tolle story große
bilder und gegen 0.15 meldet sich
christopher wehrmann mit unserem
heute-journal abdeckt
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter bisher hat es im
mai ausreichend für viel geregnet
teilweise sogar in einigen regionen mehr
als normal arbeiten der tiefe kommt das
wasser relativ schwer an
und so herrscht immer noch eine schwere
dürre und teils außergewöhnlichen dürre
zum beispiel im osten deutschlands oder
im süden ja es regnete in den nächsten
tagen zwar weiter aber um diese dollar
auszugleichen müsste es mehrere monate
hinweg überdurchschnittlich viel regnen
ja und wir schauen auf das wetter so
sieht es aus von nordwesten kommt kalte
luft das april wetter setzt sich quasi
weiter fort und vor allem im süden kommt
ihr kräftiger regen auf und das bereits
in der kommenden nacht von westen her
also viele wolken mit kräftigen regen im
norden sind es schauer und gewitter
sonst ist es im osten und im süden
trocken hier gehen die temperaturen an
den alpen bis auf 0 grad zurück im
südwesten deutschlands bis auf 10 grad
sonst liegen wir bei drei bis neun grad
morgen also viel los im norden schauer
und gewitter erneut muss man sagen die
durchziehen teilweise mit kräftigen wind
im süden auch viel wind dazu viel regen
der sich allmählich nach süden durch
setzt ganz im süden an den alpen da
bleibt es am längsten trocken teils mit
sonnigen abschnitten und das bei
höchsten temperaturen dort bis 18 grad
sonst liegen wir zwischen 10 und 16 grad
und die kommenden tage
am donnerstag setzt sich das
schauerwetter weiter vor teils mit
kräftigen gewittern bei 12 bis 19 grad
ab freitag wird es von westen her
allmählich drucker mit sonnenschein
werte bis 21 grad damit ein schöner
abend